wijajang is at the white house where
president biden is now weighing his
response that includes sending more
troops to eastern europe rishi good
morning a lot of americans waking up
going what exactly does that mean
good morning president biden spent the
weekend at camp david huddling with his
national security team about the current
state of russian military operations cbs
news has learned that mr biden is
considering sending several thousand u.s
troops and equipment to reinforce the
eastern flank of nato which could
include countries like lithuania and
latvia who share borders with russia
those nato nations have to request the
assistance first and that number of u.s
troops could also increase tenfold if
russia conducts a full-blown invasion
the white house still believes there is
a path forward with diplomacy and
dialogue why the u.s has not pulled the
trigger on sanctions just yet secretary
of state anthony blinken argued on face
the nation that if the u.s does that
before vladimir putin prompts further
aggression it would lose the power to
keep russia at bay
several republican members of congress
opposed the decision to hold off on
issuing sanctions they are urging
president biden to take action now to
send a message to putin and to show
american strength
we'll be waiting on news from president
biden ouija thank you